طيب اردوغان الرئيس الثاني عشر لتركيا منذ
18 اعوام شرف على ان ينهي السبعين من عمره
وكذلك على امل ان يجدد عهد الرئاسه في
الانتخابات المرتقبه في يونيو المقبل
تراجعت شعبيته بحسب استطلاعات راي تشرح
المشهد السياسي في تركيا نصف المدنيين
اوضح انهم لن يصوتوا لاردوغان وبناء عليه
قرر ان ينفذ خطه الحرباء بحسب لموند
الفرنسيه الصحيفه قالت ان اردوغان يكتسح
الساحه الدوليه بافعاله في الفتره الاخيره
ليعزز صورته الداخليه امام الاتراك الذين
بداوا واحدا تلو الاخر يفقدون الثقه
بتصرفاته وافعاله وكل ذلك من اجل الحفاظ
على السلطه ما قال ليمون فان اردوغان يملك
صفات الحرباء الفريده يمتلك مواهب
المراوغه بقدرته على تحويل الازمات الى
فرص سياسيه تجعل مباراه تتجه اليه
[موسيقى]
عشرون عاما من الحكم قدها اردوغان كرئيس
الوزراء اولا ثم كرئيس للدوله كل تلك
الاعوام بالصراعاتها ونزرعتها برز فيها
اردوغان مثيرا للصدمات تاره ومره اخرى
يفاقم التوترات ليخرج من ماء كاد ان يقضي
على سلطته فبينما يهدد بعمليه بريه ضد
الاكراد في الشمال السوري انتقاما من
التفجير الدموي في اسطنبول منتصف نوفمبر
لعب اليوم دوري الصانع السلام بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وتوسط مع الامم المتحده لفتح
ثلاثه موان اوكرانيه على البحر الاسود
لتصدير الحبوب والقمح وبالفعل اعلنت اخراج
اكثر من 13 مليون طن من الحبوب من
اوكرانيا ومنذ بدا تطبيق اتفاقيه اسطنبول
الموقعه في الثانيه والعشرين من يوليو
الماضي حتى ان تركيا دات الغربه العدم
يحرق الجسور مع روسيا والتوصل الى تسويه
بين الجانبين كما ان المصافحه التاريخيه
على ارض قطر تصدرت عناوين العلاقات
التركيه المصريه بين اردوغان ونظيره عبد
الفتاح السيسي كان قبلها قد رفض رفضا
قاطعا ان يقابله لكنه بدل لونه اقصد رايه
قال لا خلاف ابديا في السياسه جمله قالها
لمصر وقرر لسوريا مع وساطه روسيه ليلتقي
بالرئيس الرئيس السوري رئيس النظام بشار
الاسد بعد ان كان عدوه اللدود
اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى ان تاريخ اردوغان
حافل بتغيير المواقف وربما الايدولوجيات
استشهدت الصحيفه بعلاقاته مع ثلاثه رؤساء
سابقين لامريكا بدا من جورج بوش الذي راى
باردوغان المسلمه المتحمس يلهيب اوباما
الذي اعتبر علاقته باردوغان تفتح له نافذه
على العالم الاسلامي اما دونالد ترامب
الشهير بحبه للادوار فاشاد باردوغان وقال
انه صانع الصفقه
[موسيقى]